Yo les gens c'est Squeezie.
C'était un prank, c'est Fabien Olicard !
Vous avez deux vidéos en une.
Maintenant que le prank est passé, on va parler de ça.
Alors oui, cette semaine, vous avez vu,
c'est un plus petit casse tête que la Pandora Box.
Des fois j'en ferai des plus simples
et des fois des plus compliqués.
Celui-ci, je pressens qu'il va me faire galérer
parce qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup d'actions possibles.
Et en général,
quand il n'y a pas beaucoup d'actions possibles, c'est vraiment pas bon signe.
Mais il y a une chose qui est sûre,
c'est que ça, ça ne sert à rien.
J'ai demandé, et en fait c'est juste vraiment
pour en faire un porte-clés donc...
Voilà, il ne faut pas que je m'en serve
pour faire quoi que ce soit.
Donc le but du jeu,
c'est simplement d'enlever... "simplement"
...l'étoile du serpent,
parce que c'est un serpent qui se mord la queue,
et ensuite, comme dans tout bon casse tête,
si tu l'enlèves, tu dois être capable de le remettre.
Ca va pas être simple.
J'ai quoi ? Je détaille avec vous -
J'ai quatre branches identiques,
c'est un élément, et deux plus petites,
il y en a une de chaque côté.
Bon alors je vais essayer des trucs classiques qui...
ça ne va servir à rien, voilà,
c'est à dire qu'en fait tu essaies d'en passer une
et t'es obligé de faire une rotation
et en fait elle garde toujours...
Ah oui, d'accord en fait...
pas du tout
*rires*
C'est tellement relou ça dans les casses têtes aussi...ah ouais, mais non...
En fait y a en permanence,
les deux petites branches qui se mettent naturellement une de chaque côté...
Ou alors elles sont centrées, mais...
Ah oui d'accord, ok.
Je pourrais garder ça comme ça, voilà c'est ça...
Si je les oublie elles,
ça passe au centre et y en a un de chaque côté,
donc c'est forcément sur une rotation
et j'imagine que la forme du serpent,
qui n'est pas un cercle parfait du tout d'ailleurs.
En fait, c'est chaud,
parce que j'ai l'impression de faire des gestes différents mais..
Ah put***, t'es là en mode
"Eh ! Je crois qu'il se passe quelque chose mon gars !"
Là en vrai j'ai fait un truc là.
Non, en fait, ouais d'accord, comme tout est symétrique, je peux avoir l'impression de faire un truc
et au final,
je me retrouve toujours dans la même config...
Est-ce que vous aviez vu
qu'en ce moment je faisais des vidéos sur Instagram ?
Sinon, vous pouvez cliquer juste au-dessus de moi, pendant que moi je cherche.
Je comprends pas comment ça se fait
qu'il y ait si peu de monde sur Instagram.
Bah ça c'est un autre casse tête
qui va falloir que je résolve un jour.
Comment on peut être suivi
par 750 000 personnes sur YouTube
et par si peu de monde sur Instagram ?
Non... Ah ! Non... *Rires*
Je m'suis tellement fait un truc...
Ah mais non, mais attends, j'ai dit que les quatre branches avaient la même...
Ah oui... mais pas dans ce sens là.
Donc je pense
qu'il faut aller chercher une rotation en coin
et peut-être faire une rotation dans le mouvement.
Donc je sais pas si je suis très clair,
mais je me dis si je tourne en partant d'un coin
et en allant vers l'autre coin,
est-ce que là il n'y a pas un truc, un coup à faire ?
C'était pas mal dans l'idée,
mais ça n'a strictement rien donné.
Après, c'est terrible, parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'en forçant je pourrais y arriver.
Déjà, je pense que c'est faux, et je pense surtout
qu'il n'y a pas un casse tête au monde
qui existe avec comme solution "tu dois forcer".
Ça donne envie quand même d'appuyer fort.
Si j'avais les deux petits du même côté, je sortirais...
Ah ! Ou alors...
Vous savez, j'ai commencé cette vidéo avec Loïc,
il y a deux jours,
et puis à un moment donné, il est parti, je n'ai plus eu de nouvelles...
Loïc, si tu es là, fais bouger cette table.
C'est notre scientifique du fait qu'il ne soit pas là.
Je sais que tu cherches une connerie à dire,
ou pas.
Mais moi pendant ce temps-là,
j'ai résolu un casse-tête.
Boom !
Défaire un casse tête, c'est une chose.
Le refaire, c'est-à-dire le remettre,
c'est la manière de prouver qu'on a bien compris comment ça marche, et je vais être honnête avec vous...
J'ai essayé des rotations en translation,
comme ça, tout en parlant pour ne rien dire,
et un moment donné,
j'ai vu que ça marchait et que je l'avais enlevé.
Je sais pas comment ! *Rires*
Je sais pas du tout comment j'ai fait.
OK, en tout cas,
ça a été via mon système de rotation pour le mettre.
En plus, il est terrible ce casse-tête,
parce qu'au départ quand tu l'as en main,
il a l'air hyper fragile,
genre tu vas faire ça, ça va tomber.
Et tellement pas.
Quand ça, ça l'entoure,
la partie métallique elle doit entourer à moité
les quatre branches identiques.
Donc si je veux reproduire ça,
il faut déjà que je sois exactement comme ça
donc là, deux grandes branches d'un côté,
deux de l'autre,
sauf qu'il y en a un des deux petits
qui devrait être de l'autre côté.
Du coup...
Alors, si je rentre un petit...
Si je rentre un petit et un grand,
ça veut dire qu'il me reste un grand à rentrer.
Merci de jamais isoler cette phrase de cette vidéo.
Vous voyez, ça c'est vraiment typique
du gars qui a réussi son casse-tête
sans trop savoir comment il l'avait fait.
Ce qui serait drôle,
c'est que vous ayez le même casse-tête
et que vous soyez en train de le résoudre en même temps que moi. On pourrait faire un battle.
C'est sûr que dans le nombre,
y en a qui réussiraient avant moi.
En plus, là, vous vous êtes en vacances, vous êtes en plein été, et moi je suis en train de me stresser, si ça se trouve vous êtes
en train de me regarder à la plage.
Peut-être même en lisant mon deuxième tome... Qui a dit "placement de produit" à cette phrase, c'est impossible.
Ah oui, d'accord, OK, si c'est bon, je viens de comprendre, OK.
Donc si je viens de comprendre, ça veut dire que je suis capable de le remettre...
C'est ça !
J'annonce officiellement que ce casse-tête est résolu.
Evidemment, vous allez trouver le lien de ce casse-tête dans la description, et puis tout l'été ce sera un casse tête par semaine. Et après
tu peux activer la cloche, mais il y a aussi des vidéos en plus, peut-être en bonus, peut-être pas... Tu peux t'abonner à mon Instagram
à mon Dailymotion où les vidéos sont en avance. Mais surtout, tu n'entends que le son de ma voix
tu lâches un like, et tu t'abonnes à cette chaîne YouTube.
Parce que ça fait plaisir...
Passez de bonnes vacances. Mon nouveau livre est sorti. Il y a trop de trucs à dire en fait ! Rendez-vous à l'Olympia !
Ciao !